uh tell me why why now are the people
your colleagues coming out on strike so
uh we had the peer review body
announcement at the end of July it was
put into people's pay packets in
September and it delivered about four
four and a half percent when inflation's
been running at 10 11 12 and we've been
trying to negotiate with the government
since then that's we've been asking them
all the time to sit down and talk to us
about what we do about p and they have
consistently refused to talk to us about
P I mean not even a glimmer of let's
talk about it talk to us about anything
else but not pay and we've got to the
point now where there's no options so
we've asked to their members and you
know an industrial action ballot in this
country takes about 10 weeks so we
haven't deliberately picked Christmas
time this just happens to be the time
when we were able to take strike action
now the government say that they've been
led by a recommendations from an
independent pay review body that's what
they're following times of time off you
have to cut the cloth everyone's
struggling is that good enough no it's
not and they're hiding behind the peer
review body the people who set the pay
peer review of their makes a
recommendation and the people who are
responsible for setting the pay in this
country for for NHS workers uh the
Secretary of State for health and the
Prime Minister and uh and they're just
hiding behind us it's one it's not
really independent and everybody knows
that we've known it for years but
secondly this has been a pretty
exceptional year I would say you know
we've had that horrendous budget a few
months ago which put everything out of
kilter practically destroyed the economy
inflation shows no sign of going down
this year we've had a huge energy price
increases and these people are feeling
that just as anybody else is feeling it
and so it would have been entirely
legitimate for the government to say do
you know what either recall the peer
review body to give us another
recommendation or we recognize this is
an exceptional year and we're going to
do something about it lots of employers
have done that this year so lots of like
the retail industry as the Tesco
Sainsbury's have all given their staff
not only one but two and in some cases
three pay increases this year to
recognize that and which then to the
government these people do an amazing
job and you're treating them with huge
disrespect by saying you won't sit down
and even talk to us again that was
something you was quite clear you're
quite frustrated aren't you about that
yeah I mean I all I get is told all the
time we can't talk to the P we can't
talk to you about people talk to you
about rotors we'll talk to you about new
build hospitals we'll talk to you about
all sorts of things well we can talk to
them about that any day of the week this
is not why we're on strike and we're on
strike because without paying you can't
keep staff in the ambulance service and
that puts patients at risk this
government is putting patience okay
Christina mcinay thank you very much for
joining us